en france 24 damos inicio a una serie de
reportajes dedicada a la labor de los
recicladores vamos a comenzar en
colombia un colectivo en bogotá la
capital ha visto mejorar sus condiciones
de trabajo en los últimos años ya que
ahora son reconocidos oficialmente como
prestadores del servicio público de
reciclaje sin embargo la mayoría de
ellos ganan menos de 200 dólares
mensuales muy por debajo del salario
mínimo colombiano este reportaje es de
lionel puse allí y hace parte de la
serie de publicaciones por la beca de
producción periodística sobre reciclaje
inclusivo ejecutada con el apoyo de la
fundación gabo y latitudes
y los seres creadores de bogotá han
visto mejorar significativamente sus
condiciones de trabajo estos últimos
años estos son miembros de una de las
160 organizaciones de recicladores de la
capital colombiana ahora son reconocidos
oficialmente como prestadores del
servicio público de reciclaje
ahora es un diputado mucho porque por lo
menos podemos presentarnos más ante la
pues conozcan soy reguladora y se mire
mi carne o seas artística muchas cosas y
es un orgullo tener del formal pero el
mayor reconocimiento no es el más
visible los 16 mil recicladores de
bogotá miembros de una organización
tienen desde 2013 dos fuentes de
ingresos
la principal viene de la venta del
material que recolectan la segunda se
llama tarifa de aprovechamiento una
retribución pagada por los habitantes de
bogotá dentro de la factura de aseo en
el caso de ley y representa entre 25 y
30 dólares mensuales el 20 por ciento de
sus ingresos
igualmente la tarifa también es
voluntaria son pues porque nos ayuda
para los gastos de la pasa bastante este
sistema es único en américa latina para
obtenerlo los haberes y creadores
colombianos enfrentaron al estado
colombiano ante la corte constitucional
nora padilla fue la cabeza de este
movimiento la corte constitucional le da
la razón a los recicladores y no
solamente orden a la protección del
oficio en manos de los recicladores
además ordena que se haga una
remuneración a los recicladores porque
lo que nosotros hacemos es lo mismo que
hacen las otras empresas privadas que
era recoger basura pero este complemento
de ingresos sigue siendo insuficiente
para sacar a los tres creadores de la
pobreza la mayoría de ellos ganan menos
de doscientos dólares mensuales por
debajo del salario mínimo colombiano